the Joe Rogan experience I'm the only
one in the UFC broadcast that doesn't
put makeup on - yeah and I'm like we're
getting we're talking to people that are
getting their heads punched in ok
literally you want to you and Jay check
who's the former straw weight champion
and she had a fight with this woman
Zhang Wei Lee who is the straw weight
champion yeah from China it's crazy epic
like one of the best fights in history
at the end of it
you want his head I saw this is so slow
like a Frankenstein forehead yeah
imagine me yeah look at her forehead now
imagine me with makeup on standing next
or that would be ridiculous right I
refuse look at my foundation there's
like walls we're just gonna cut down on
the shine who gives a [ __ ] if I'm shiny
yeah literally no one cares yeah she's
got a double forehead now it's a double
triple for us I backed it back down I
don't know she doesn't follow up she
hasn't taken that's what she looks like
normally beautiful lady she's so tough
yeah that lady is as tough as human
beings can possibly be cuz she like
never even flinched her [ __ ]
foreheads twice the size of normal she
didn't even flinch kept throwing bombs
was amazing yeah epic how long did it go
five rounds five twenty five whole
minutes of chaos like and it was even
the whole fight the whole fight was like
back and forth and back and forth back
and forth it was amazing
[Applause]